foreign
[Music]
box today we're getting our first look
at the arc A380 Intel's first generation
discrete GPU codenamed Alchemist or the
architecture that's based on its code
named Alchemist this is well it's an
unofficial review let's say because
Intel is yet to sort of start their own
official review program and in a lot of
ways they haven't
officially released this product at
least not worldwide so the only release
so far for this product has been inside
China and that means I purchased this
model here for
why way too much money from an eBay
seller in China but despite that I
appreciate being able to get my hands on
one early and of course thank you to our
patreon and float plane members who
helped make content like this possible
along with
today's sponsor spot is brought to you
by be quiet and the new FX range which
adds argb lighting to some of our
favorite big white products their new
purebase 500 FX case comes with four
pre-installed be quiet lightwings fans
complete with internal and external argb
lighting then for cooling you have the
option of either air or liquid the pure
rock 2 FX is the pure rock 2 black that
we all know and love but now with a
lightwings 120 millimeter fan likewise
the pure Loop has been upgraded to the
pure Loop 2 FX with a new and improved
pump that supports pwm control supports
radiators up to 360 millimeters and of
course up to three light Wings high
speed argb fans discounts of up to 30 us
can be had when you purchase any FX
product between now and the end of
September so to find out more please
click the links in the video description
okay so like everyone else who has
managed to get their hands on an A380 so
far we have the Gunner Photon model
which I have to say it does look like a
rather well put together graphics card
but for now we're more interested in the
arc 3 A380 GPU this will be Intel's most
entry level offering in The Alchemist
liner expected to cost somewhere between
120 and 130 us which would make it the
cheapest new graphics card on the market
today based on tsmc's n6 process the dg2
128 die packs 7.2 billion transistors
inside a 157 millimeter square die as
for the core configuration there are
1024 cores 64 tmus and 32 rops then for
the memory we have 6 Gigabytes of 15.5
gigabits per second gddr6 memory on a
96-bit wide bus for a bandwidth of 186
gigabytes per second which is comparable
to that of the GeForce GTX 1650. now in
terms of features all Alchemist gpus
support av1 fixed function Hardware
encoding DisplayPort 2.0 DirectX 12
ultimate Hardware base Road tracing and
xcss or super sampling based on neural
networks so similar to nvidia's dlss so
at least in terms of features these new
arc gpus will rival that of current
generation AMD and Nvidia Parts
performance though and driver support
well that could be a totally different
story as I'm sure many of you are aware
at this point as several other media
Outlets have already gotten their hands
on the A380 Intel still has a lot of
work to do on the driver front and there
are also a few strange quirks such as
the need for resizable bar support in
order to deliver acceptable performance
therefore our plan is to First cover the
A380 with our standard review format
which is exactly what we're doing now
and then in the next week or two
establish Baseline performance across a
far broader range of games so 30 plus
hopefully up around 50 if I'm up to the
task I suspect and of course hope that
Intel will continue to work on driver
support and make good improvements there
over the coming months and years so by
getting all this data now we can monitor
that progress as it happens so with that
let's get into The Benchmark results for
testing I'm using a ryzen 9 5950x GPU
test system and I know no one is going
to pay a budget graphics card with this
CPU but of course that's not the point
we're testing GPU performance and
therefore wish to avoid introducing any
other kind of system bottleneck which
could skew the data now for our low end
to entry level testing we typically use
medium quality settings or settings that
make sense for a given title also please
note that the A380 has been tested with
and without resizable bar enabled
whereas all other gpus have been tested
with rebar disabled but this is
something I'd like to update in the
future finally I've tested at 1080P and
1440p but for this video I'm going to
focus on the more relevant 1080p results
while the 1440p graphs will be made
available to float plane and patreon
members okay let's get into it
starting with Assassin's Creed Valhalla
we find that the A380 isn't exactly the
snappiest of gpus 48 fps at 1080p using
the medium quality preset is it so
better than the old GTX 1050 tier I
guess but 11 slower than the RX 6400
when that part is afforded pcie 4.0
bandwidth probably more disappointing
though is the fact that it is nine
percent slower than the RX 570 and now a
five-year-old graphics card that started
life at just 170 U.S still the game was
playable so I guess there's that though
I should note you absolutely need rebar
enabled as Intel recommends otherwise
you will be limited to just 36 FPS on
average with weaker and frankly
unplayable one percent lows of 23 FPS
next up we have shot of the Tomb Raider
and performance here is downright
horrible with just 42 FPS on average at
1080P and although we are using the
highest quality settings the old RX 570
was good for just 54 FPS and the RX 6400
53 FPS that's it if we limit the RX 6400
to PCI 3.0 bandwidth that is comparable
with the A380 of course though you will
want to make sure rebar is enabled
because without it the game wasn't
playable under these conditions though
it possibly would be if we lowered the
quality settings
moving on to watchdog's Legion the
results here are more promising though
we're still only looking at RX 570 or RX
6400 light performance still 59 FPS on
average with the medium quality presets
very playable and it's certainly
competitive with the RX 6400 again
though you need rebar support because
without it the A380 quickly becomes a
GTX 1050 TI
next up we have Rainbow Six Siege and
like Watchdogs Legend the performance is
reasonable here relative to the
competition in fact it's a bit better
than that matching the Radeon RX 6500 XT
and in fact the one percent lows were
quite a bit better it's still not quite
GTX 1650 or RX 570 performance but still
114 FPS on average using the ultra
quality settings is a good result here
and far better than that of the RX 6400
they'll once again be aware that rebar
is required as without a performance
will drop by as much as 26 percent
with F1 2021 the A380 is back to
delivering RX 6400 light performance
which I guess given the expected price
will be okay and the performance overall
was very playable and not too bad given
that we are using high quality settings
of course as we've come to learn rebar
is mandatory and without it the game was
unplayable with one percent lows of just
22 FPS
next we have Horizon zero Dawn and again
we're looking at RX 570 and RX 6400
light performance so 50 FPS on average
not horrible I suppose though again as I
found over and over now rebar will be
required as without it the A380 is
slower than even the GTX 1050 TI
the Far Cry 6 performance was very
lackluster just 52 FPS on average Which
is less than that of the GTX 1650 and on
par with the RX 6400 when limited to PCI
3.0 but 22 slower than the 6400 when
using PCI 4.0 and then 22 slower than
the RX 570 so that's not good
do maternal performance was reasonable
56 FPS at 1080p using the ultra quality
preset is an 8 increase over the RX 6400
but still 10 slower than the old RX 570
the game was playable though so that is
a huge positive for the A380 and it
would seem about where we're starting
the bar at this point
frame rates in Resident Evil Village
were also reasonable 68 FPS on average
meant the A380 was slightly faster than
the GTX 1650 but once again slower than
the much older RX 570 now with the rebar
disabled the average frame rate still
looks quite reasonable and normally 58
FPS would be very playable but the one
percent lows were horrible leading to a
very stuttery gaming experience
the death stranding results are more
concerning as here the A380 is 13 slower
than the RX 6400 and 15 slower than the
RX 570 as it only matched the already
very underwhelming GTX 1650. again
though the game was playable so if you
set the bar low enough the A380 does get
a pass as long as rebar is supported and
enabled because without it the arc GPU
was basically broken in this title
yeah the second last game tested is
Hitman 3 and this is another rough title
for the A380 which only saw GTX 1650
light performance making it slower than
both the RX 570 and RX 6400 of course 58
FPS on average with one percent lows of
53 FPS is playable so there is that but
without rebar the one percent lows did
drop 226 FPS and here the experience was
horrible unplayable even
finally we have cyberpunk 2077 and I was
pretty shocked to see the A380 doing
quite well here relative to Parts such
as the RX 6400 and RX 570 both of which
it beat by a 16 margin when rebar was
enabled sadly though 44 FPS on average
at 1080p using the medium quality preset
is at best a sub-optimal gaming
experience but relative to other budget
graphics cards I suppose it is a pass
now moving on to power consumption we
see that the A380 which is reasonably
light on power usage it's still not
quite where it needs to be total system
usage was pushed up to 233 Watts so
slightly higher than that of the GTX
1650 super and that's a GPU that on
average was a bit over 40 faster in our
testing ideally the A380 would want to
be down below the RX 6400 here but in
reality though for most Gamers the
difference here won't matter as the arc
graphics card still works just fine with
low end budget power suppliers
now for looking at the cooling
performance I recorded the gameplay with
an on-screen display using the Intel
Graphics Command Center so the A380 was
used for the video encoding here
admittedly I am yet to really properly
play around with this but I wasn't able
to record gameplay without extremely
choppy feedback the game though ran
quite smooth and certainly a lot
smoother than you're seeing here anyway
for the purpose of recording the
operating statistics it still works so
I'll just use it when gaming the Gunner
of photon A380 peaked at just 60 degrees
with a fan speed of no more than 1600
RPM making it a very cool and quiet
graphics card so that is a positive the
GPU is typically seen clocked at 2.4
gigahertz and the memory operated at the
advertised 15.5 gigabits per second so
overall a good quality graphics card
it's just a shame about the frame rate
performance okay time for the Dozen game
breakdown as expected the results aren't
great the A380 is at best only able to
match the rx6400 and all GTX 1650 making
it on average 11 slower than the 5 year
old RX 570 and way slower than the 5500
XT which shares a similar size die in
short I hated the performance we
received from the RX 6400 so I can't say
I'm overly impressed with the arc A380
although it is only early days for
Intel's Alchemist architecture and the
entry-level Arc A380 which technically
still hasn't been released yet at least
not outside of China
so yeah to say the situation for Intel
is extremely concerning right now I
think that's a massive understatement
and we always knew like some of this
isn't unexpected we always knew that
drivers would be the Achilles heel of
any intel discrete GPU venture
and perhaps that's all we're looking at
here perhaps it's just a lack of driver
development that could improve over the
coming months and years frankly though
that is probably a best case scenario as
more recently it's been suggested that
Intel's been stalling the release of
their Arc series due to fundamental
hardware issues that can't be resolved
by drivers alone of course at this point
in time we don't know how true this is
and really it is just a rumor but I
think it's also fair to say the expected
a rough start has been just that in fact
the rumor mill has been running hot in
regards to Intel Arc news with many
suggesting the Intel is seriously
considering canceling the entire project
allegedly considering it too expensive
with no clear road to profit and with
the release continually pushed back and
yet to actually happen outside of China
We Fear the rumors could end up being
true frankly it'll be really really
disappointing if they don't continue to
push forward Intel's first generation of
discrete gpus was never going to be
profitable the execution was never going
to be Flawless or even smooth and it was
always going to take three or four
generations before they started to get
on their feet we would have assumed
Intel knew this and had budgeted for it
but if the rumors are true apparently
not rumors aside though the A380 is
clearly disappointing but I don't think
it's a lost cause assuming further
driver development can pretty up the
picture a bit granted it's a complete
mess with that resizable bar but for now
I'd like to think Arc is sort of a
forward-thinking investment and he tell
themselves has said that support for
older games won't be great the focus is
really on new titles using modern apis
so DirectX 12 and Vulcan for example
clearly they're also focusing on new pc
Hardware as well as the A380 is a
horrible pairing for an older PC that
doesn't support resizable bar and in the
current condition you absolutely need to
enable rebar if you're going to use an
arc GPU of course the question of
whether or not you should buy an Intel
GPU when they're eventually released
can't be definitively answered just yet
that said in its current condition along
with the uncertain future of Intel's
discrete GPU program the answer is quite
clearly no there's also the matter of
pricing and let's just assume for a
moment that the rumors are all wrong so
forget basically everything we just
discussed meaning Intel is 100 committed
to Arc and its driver development if the
A380 were to hit shelves for around
let's say 120 to 130 U.S which is about
50 U.S less than the RX 6400 should you
buy it I'd say if the only alternative
was the RX 6400 my graphics card I very
much despise unless you need it for a
low profile application I could see
myself gambling on the A380 mostly
because I don't care for playing older
games anymore you also get Hardware
encoding which I very much like to use
though that could probably do with some
software development you get more than
two display outputs and av1 decoding you
also also get an extra two gigabytes of
vram which has already proven
particularly handy and then the pcie
times 16 interface should help to
mitigate any performance related issues
when maxing out the vram buffer or
getting close to maxing it out however
for Gamers on a tight budget either the
A380 or rx6400 wouldn't make my
recommendation anyway rather I'd suggest
checking out your local used market and
over on ebay.com for example RX 570s
regularly sell for around a hundred
dollars while GTX 1650 supers go for
more like 150 and both are faster than
either the RX 6400 or A380 Intel
certainly has a lot of work ahead of
them and I sincerely hope they can
eventually position themselves as a
legitimate third competitor in the
discrete GPU Market
but for now that's not looking
particularly promising I have to say and
we'll leave it at that for now consider
this somewhat of a preview hopefully
there'll be a lot more Arc related stuff
coming up on the channel over the next
few months if you enjoyed this video
please do give it a like subscribe for
more content and if you'd like to see
that 30 40 50 game Benchmark comparing
this head to head with the radon RX 6400
in a range of games made with a few
different quality settings then let me
know in the comment section below and
perhaps I can make that happen
also if you'd like to become a harbor
box Community member float plane patreon
links flows are in the video description
we've got access to our exclusive
Discord server monthly live streams q
and A's behind the scenes content a lot
of cool stuff there so check it out if
you're interested but if not perfectly
fine and I would like to just thank you
for watching this video I'm your host
Dave and I'll see you again next time
foreign
[Music]